chers collègues nous avons donc
aujourd'hui le plaisir de recevoir
Monsieur Pierre Moscovici premier
président de la Cour des comptes en sa
qualité de président du Conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires institution
associée à la Cour des comptes je salue
également les personnes qui
l'accompagnent notamment monsieur Lefa
que nous connaissons bien dans cette
assemblée le CPO a rendu public le 9
février dernier un rapport intitulé La
taxe sur la valeur ajoutée un impôt à
recentrer sur son objectif de rendement
pour les finances publiques
ce n'est pas la première fois que le CPO
s'intéresse à la TVA puisqu'il y a déjà
consacré un rapport en décembre 2015 qui
aboutissait si je ne m'abuse des
conclusions similaires ou quasi
similaire la TVA est un impôt de
rendement qui doit fournir des
ressources à la puissance publique en
conséquence il ne faut toucher pour
paraphraser Montesquieu que d'une main
tremblante au risque de perte de perdre
de précieuses recettes pour des
résultats incertains
pour autant dans un contexte
inflationniste
pesant sur le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages et de demande de soutien à la
transition énergétique les voies se
multiplient pour abaisser encore les
taux de TVA sur certains produits que
l'on change à la TVA sur les billets de
Trump par exemple de plus on constate
depuis quelques années une distribution
beaucoup plus large du produit de la TVA
à d'autres acteurs publics que l'État
que faire face à ces évolutions
sans aller plus loin sur le fond du
rapport je vous salue la parole monsieur
le Président pour que vous puissiez le
présenter à la commission avant
d'engager le débat je vous rappelle
monsieur le Président de votre audition
fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat le président
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
cher Claude Raynal monsieur le
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs merci de m'avoir invité à
vous présenter le rapport du Conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires qui a été
adopté le 17 janvier dernier sur la taxe
c'est la valeur ajoutée j'ai toujours
grand plaisir à vous retrouver et je
suis heureux que cette occasion nous
soit fournie par cette audition la
mission du Conseil des prélèvements
obligatoires comme vous l'avez dit
organisme associé à la Cour des comptes
et bien de nourrir le débat public
d'éclairer la décision et de contribuer
à votre contrôle sur les dépenses et les
recettes publiques en tant que président
du CPO comme en tant que Premier
président de la Cour des comptes ou
encore président du Conseil des finances
publiques j'ai ce rôle là très à coeur
ainsi que de veiller à l'excellente
qualité de relation que nous
institutions entretiennent avec la
représentation nationale
avec le rapport que je vous présente
aujourd'hui le Conseil des premières
obligatoires traitent d'un sujet qu'il
avait en effet traité en 2015 mais qui
n'avait pas traité par définition depuis
je suis accompagné de Patrick Lefa qui
est avec moi en charge du CPO et du
rapporteur général monsieur decrovoisier
et je remercie d'ailleurs le rapporteur
général et toute l'équipe de rapporteurs
qui a fourni un travail très important
ce rapport approfondie est le fruit d'un
travail conséquent il est concis celui
2015 était près de 5 fois plus
volumineux il répond à l'ambition que
j'ai fixée au CPO comme à la cour d'être
encore davantage au service des citoyens
grâce à des travaux qui soient plus
accessibles mais aussi plus en prise
avec le monde de la recherche académique
il est enrichi par des comparaisons
internationales qui font ressortir que
la France se distingue par une taxation
la consommation inférieure à celle des
pays européens comparables il est enfin
assorti d'une dizaine de recommandations
directement opérationnelle la TVA
représente la troisième catégorie de
prélèvements obligatoires dans les
comptes nationaux son rendement est de
186 milliards d'euros en 2021 derrière
les cotisations sociales qui
représentent 34 % des prélèvements et
les recettes d'imposition des revenus
quand je dis des revenus c'est à la fois
l'imposition sur le revenu et la CSG 26%
des prélèvements mais en réalité si on
ne raisonne plus en termes de grande
catégories de prélèvement mais d'impôts
c'est la première imposition en France
devant la CSG 129 milliards d'euros
l'impôt sur le revenu 80 milliards et
l'impôt sur les sociétés 46 milliards je
précise que tous les chiffres concernent
2021 aujourd'hui vous le savez 5 taux de
TVA sont applicables en France
métropolitaine en complément de taux
spécifiques en Corse et dans trois
territoires
ultramars
à l'évidence une fois que j'ai prononcé
ces chiffres on voit que l'environnement
est devenu plus complexe qu'en 2015
parce que l'encadrement européen a été
assoupli et quand j'étais commissaire
européen je l'ai souhaité il me semblait
en effet qu'il fallait redonner plus de
marge de manœuvre aux États membres sur
leur taux de TVA parce que de nouveaux
types de fraude sont apparus parce que
de nouveaux débats ont émergé autour du
pilotage conjoncturel de l'économie de
la réponse au choc énergétique ou encore
des défis environnementaux et de santé
publique dans ce contexte on pourrait
dire que le trésor rapport est tout
entier contenu dans son titre il
s'articule autour de deux messages clés
qui sont des messages simples le premier
message est celui de la nécessité de
maintenir le rendement de la TVA pour
les finances publiques la TVA est une
source essentielle de ressources
fiscales pour l'État son rendement est
entamé par des taux réduits nombreux qui
pèsent fortement sur l'assiette de
l'impôt
qui mythe cette assiette et qui diminue
son produit et notre message c'est que
il ne faut pas les au-delà et le
deuxième message clé c'est que moduler
les taux de TVA n'est pas monsieur le
Président je lui dis tout de suite
l'outil plus adapté pour faire face aux
chocs énergétique à la crise énergétique
ou défi environnemental autrement dit
une préconisons pas l'usage de la TVA
comme instrument de politique
conjoncturelle voilà deux messages très
simple sur lesquels je pourrais presque
m'arrêter mais je vais quand même les
développer le premier c'est qu'il faut
maintenir le rendement de la TVA pour
financer les services publics trois
principales problématiques menacent
aujourd'hui le rendement de la TVA pour
l'État la première c'est celle de
l'affectation de la TVA à d'autres
administrations publiques en 2021 l'État
ne perçoit plus qu'environ la moitié des
recettes de TVA contre 93% 2015 vous
voyez là marche d'escalier qui a
descendu en raison d'affectuation
croissante aux organismes de protection
sociale et aux collectivités
territoriales en 2023 la TVA constituera
la première ressource des collectivités
territoriales avec un total de
53,2 milliards d'euros en loi de finance
initiale ces affectations répondent à
des choix structurants d'organisation
des relations financières entre l'État
et les autres administrations publiques
elle pose néanmoins une question
essentielle qui essaie de la
soutenabilité des finances publiques
puisqu'elle a pour effet de contracter
les ressources fiscales de l'État alors
que le niveau de dépenses publiques a
financé lui reste inchangé par ailleurs
des affectations de TVA ont parfois lieu
en dehors du champ des collectivités
territoriales ou des organismes de
sécurité sociale comme par exemple pour
l'audiovisuel public qui bénéficie de
3,8 milliards d'euros de recettes de TVA
en LFI pour 2023 en compensation vous le
savez de la suppression de la
contribution
l'audiovisuel public la redevance le CPO
recommande de la manière la plus claire
d'éviter désormais les affectations de
TVA en dehors des deux champs des
collectivités territoriales et des
organismes de sécurité sociale
ces dernières seront au demeurants je
parle des affectations en dehors de ces
champs interdites à compter de 2025 en
application de l'article 2 modifié de la
loi organique relative aux lois de
finances qui imposent un lien entre les
recettes fiscales affectées et les
missions de service public conférées à
l'organisme public affectateur au-delà
de l'enjeu de son affectation la
deuxième problématique majeure autour du
rendement de la TVA et le développement
de la fraude
les récentes estimations de la fraude à
la TVA sont plus importantes que les
précédentes Lindsay chiffre les
irrégularités qu'elle soit
intentionnelle ou non entre 20 et 26
milliards d'euros sur la base de données
de 2012 mais la méthode suivie reste
fragile notamment parce qu'elle ne prend
pas en compte les comportements
frauduleux frauduleux non détectés par
les contrôleurs si certains de schémas
de fraude à la TVA tels que la fraude
carrousel et les commisses souterraines
sont désormais bien identifiées de
nouveaux mécanismes frauduleux
apparaissent en lien avec la
numérisation de l'économie plusieurs
types de fraudes continuent d'affecter
les importations des tatiaires la
sous-valorisation du produit par le
vendeur qui permet par exemple de passer
en dessous du seuil de 150 euros la
dissimulation de la qualité du vendeur
l'usure passion du numéro iOS qui est le
guichet unique du TVA au sein l'Union
européenne c'est fraude concerne
l'évitement tout autant des droits de
douane qui n'est pas notre sujet
d'aujourd'hui que la TVA à ce titre le
paquet Teva dit i-commerce entrée en
vigueur en 2021 révise profondément le
cadre juridique des importations dans
l'Union européenne en provenance des
tatiaire c'est une avancée notable le
CPO suggère d'aller plus loin en
accentuant le contrôle des plateformes
de vente de biensière à l'Union
européenne en rendant les plateformes de
mise en relation par voie électronique
rojades de la TVA et en harmonisant la
facturation électronique au sein de
l'Union européenne le récent paquet TVA
à l'ère numérique présenté par la
Commission européenne le 8 décembre 2022
va dans ce sens avec trois actions clés
le passage à la déclaration numérique en
temps réel fondée sur la facturation
électronique la remise à plat des règles
de TVA relatives au transport de
personnes et aux plateformes
d'hébergement de courte durée et
l'introduction d'un enregistrement
unique à la TVA dans l'ensemble de
l'Union européenne
ces orientations pourront utilement
alimenter les réflexions en cours sur le
plan de lutte contre les fraudes qui a
été annoncé par le gouvernement pour le
mois de mars 2023 nous les versions donc
au dossier et à votre sagacité
enfin la dernière limite au rendement de
la TVA au-delà des affectations et de la
fraude tient au tour réduit de TVA
question que vous avez soulevé monsieur
le Président c'est dérogation représente
aujourd'hui un manque à gagner d'au
moins 47 milliards d'euros en 2021 soit
près d'un quart des recettes de TVA le
coût de ces mesures est très concentré
puisque les 10 premières niches
représentent plus de 82 % du total des
mesures dérogatoires de TVA la France
compte mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs plus de mesures dérogatoires
de TVA que tout le reste de l'Union
européenne et il résulte de cette eau
dérogatoire que 65% de l'assiette totale
est soumises autonome de TVA pour une
moyenne européenne de
71%, ce qui situe la France au 19e rang
de l'Union européenne or et j'en viens
la réponse à votre question indirecte
les tours et du TVA
ont une efficacité qui apparaît très
limité pour atteindre des objectifs
économiques et constitue une source de
complexité pour les entreprises et aussi
du coup une origine de fraude
potentielle le rapport que je vous
présente suggère donc de renforcer le
suivi l'évaluation des taux réités TVA
existants par le CPO ou par une instance
Haddock et sur la base de ces
évaluations de supprimer plutôt les taux
réduits inefficaces ou à défaut de les
relever à un taux supérieur dans le
barème toujours dans l'objectif de
rendement que j'évoquais alors me
dira-t-on est-il démontré que c'est
inefficace c'est le second message du
rapport c'est montrer que la baisse de
la TVA qui est toujours tentante
politiquement né le meilleur moyen ni
pour relancer l'économie ni pour lutter
contre l'inflation ni pour conduire des
politiques sectorielles
environnementales ou sanitaires bref
disons-le
franchement carrément c'est un mauvais
outil de politique économique notamment
de politique conjoncturelle on l'utilise
trop facilement et le plus souvent à
mauvais escient en premier lieu une
baisse de TVA n'apparaît pas comme un
outil de politique conjoncturel
pertinent pour relancer les comics
françaises dans le contexte de la crise
sanitaire de 2020 plusieurs États
membres comme l'Allemagne ont procédé à
des baisses de TVA sectorielles ou
général à des fins de relance
contracyclique or les études empiriques
sur ces expériences démontent des effets
très limités pour un coût très élevé la
baisse temporaire de TVA de 2020 en
Allemagne pendant 6 mois a coûté 7
milliards d'euros soit 1,9% du budget
fédéral annuel pour un effet sur la
croissance qui était totalement marginal
en France une baisse de deux points de
TVA aurait également en effet
relativement marginal sur la croissance
évaluer à une augmentation de 0,16
points du PIB au bout d'un an en
revanche
les outils alternatifs que sont la
dépense publique et notamment
l'investissement permettrait pour un
coût équivalent équivalent des hausses
du PIB respectivement de 0,39 et 0,66 au
bout d'un an entendons-nous bien je ne
suis pas en train de proposer des
hausses de dépenses publiques je suis
juste en train de chiffrer les effets
relatifs de deux instruments
conjoncturels disons en tout cas c'est
plutôt la logique keynésienne qui
prévaut la dépense est plus efficace en
l'occurrence que la baisse de la recette
en deuxième lieu face au choc
énergétique à l'inflation qui en découle
une baisse de TVA sur les énergies
apparaît moins efficace que d'autres
instruments budgétaires ou fiscaux
différence de la plupart des voisins
européens la France a privilégié
d'autres instruments qu'une baisse de la
TVA en réponse à la hausse des prix
d'énergie pour un coût certes supérieur
mais avec une efficacité bien meilleure
les simulations conduites par le CPO
montrent que le bouclier tarifaire quoi
qu'on en pense et plus efficace qu'une
baisse de TVA à 10% sur le gaz
électricité pour réduire l'inflation et
soutenir le revenu de 12 millions de
ménages vulnérables même si les trois
fois plus coûteux 22 milliards d'euros
en 2022 et un coup présidentiel de 17
milliards d'euros en 2023 le chèque
énergie protège davantage les ménages
modestes et réduit le taux de précarité
énergétique mieux qu'une mesure de TVA
qui par définition serait non ciblée
tout en engendrant un coup moindre pour
les finances publiques 07 milliards
contre 2,7 milliards la baisse de TVA
donc mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
n’est pas c'est notre conclusion la plus
claire un outil redistributif pertinent
car son bénéfice dépend de la valeur
consommée et non comme le chèque énergie
du niveau de vie quand on est dans une
situation comme celle que nous vivons il
vaut toujours mieux privilégier des
solutions qui soient temporaires et
ciblées que des solutions générales non
ciblées durable et de surcroît en
l'occurrence
inefficace par ailleurs une baisse
durable de la TVA sur les énerves
fossiles s'inscrirait en contradiction
avec les objectifs nationaux de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre puisque celles encouragerait en
effet à long terme la priorité doit être
de modifier les comportements par des
incitations structurées à décarbonation
une réflexion générale sur la fiscalité
des énergies et sur les dispositifs
permettant d'accompagner les entreprises
et de soutenir le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages modeste apparaît donc nécessaire
mais là encore la TVA n'est pas la piste
pertinente enfin d'autres instruments
que la TVA apparaissent plus efficaces
que celle-ci pour réduire les inégalités
et pour relever les défis
environnementaux et de santé publique
d'une part s'il s'agit des inégalités
d'autres objectifs peut-être mobilisés
la modulation des taux de TVA
pour être apparaître à certains comme un
outil susceptible de lutter contre les
inégalités dans la mesure où la TVA est
un impôt régressif au sens où ça part
dans le revenu des ménages est plus
élevé on le sait pour les ménages
modestes qui consomment une part plus
grande de leurs revenus là encore on
retrouve Kens son caractère régressif
est fortement atténué quand on raisonne
sur l'ensemble du cycle de vie et quand
on prend en compte les transferts
monétaires et en nature que les recettes
de TVA financent une baisse de la TVA
par exemple sur les produits
alimentaires
par essence indifférencier selon le
niveau revenu de consommateur constitue
une mesure moins efficace pour soutenir
le pouvoir d'achat d'aménage modeste que
les transferts monétaires en raison de
l’incertitude sur les taux de
répercussion sur les prix et de
l'impossibilité de cibler certaines
catégories de ménage à travers une
baisse de TVA d'autre part
si on regarde cette fois-ci les défis
environnementaux et de santé publique
la proposition d'une TVA
environnementale ou d'une TVA moduler
selon une équitage étiquetage
alimentaire de type nutrisccor
certes à de nombreux obstacles qui
limitent les possibilités de ciblage
ainsi que son impact sur les différentes
étapes de la chaîne de valeur
tous ces éléments suggèrent clairement
de privilégier et c'est ce que nous vous
recommandons d'autres outils d'autres
instruments tels que les transversibles
les accessises le système européen
d'échange de quotas d'émission les
investissements là encore la
réglementation matière énergétique la
fiscalité nutritionnelle existante en
matière de santé publique pour
poursuivre ces objectifs qui sont des
objectifs économiques de long terme le
présent rapport aboutit une conclusion
similaire pour le soutien au secteur
économiques dit sobre que sont le
transport ferroviaire et les
commissaires en revanche le rapport
recommande systématiser l'intégration de
dimension environnementale dans les
évaluations des taux réduites TVA le CPO
s'attachera à appliquer cette
recommandation dans son prochain rapport
qui sera consacré à la fiscalité du
logement et que j'aurai le plaisir de
vous présenter si vous m'y invitez
ultérieurement
voilà c'est un rapport qui est court ma
présentation les aussi le rapport est
simple direct et concret j'ai essayé de
l'être également
parce que les messages que nous avons
réussi à dégager son rivalité
extrêmement simple et extrêmement net
avec des messages des recommandations
opérationnelles et tout entière tournée
vers les défis de l'action publique
merci de votre attention je suis à votre
disposition avec le président Lefa pour
répondre à vos questions merci monsieur
le Président j'allais d'ailleurs
démarrer mon propos par cela par ce
point c'est que ce rapport effectivement
est direct il ne laisse pas trop flotter
la réflexion il dit bon voilà en gros
c'est comme ça et j'y sens peut-être
aussi dans cette dans cette
lecture de ce rapport un petit peu moi
je l'aurais appelé presque baisse de la
TVA altofeu vous voyez un peu comme ça
ça aurait le plus bon voilà mais je peux
plus mais mais ça ressemble un peu à ça
alors je voudrais vous dire qu'avec le
rapporteur génial quand même on fait
notre job vous voyez auprès de nos
collègues
à chaque budget pls
quasiment on dit attention pas touche je
crois que les collègues peuvent le dire
ils ont même reçu cette année une note
argumentée sur le fait que il fallait
pas trop y toucher alors on a un petit
danger quand même c'est la
possibilité dans le cadre de la
directive de européenne de pouvoir
revenir un petit peu sur le toit alors
c'est à peu présenté quelques avantages
ça peut aussi présenter que vous le
savez quelques dangers toujours plus
facile d'aller vers la diminution que
vers l'augmentation et puis c'est vrai
aussi vous avez évoqué de possibles
augmentations je suis pas sûr qu'en tant
d'inflation forte que nous connaissez
aujourd'hui ce soit un message qui
passerait très bien tout de suite
voilà donc voilà quelques réserves si je
puis dire ou quelques commentaires par
rapport à votre présentation mais qui
avait qui a parce que c'est pas qui
avait qui a la valeur de nous dire
exactement
la pensée du CPO sur ce sujet monsieur
rapporteur général et merci monsieur le
Président merci
au président
Moscovici à ses équipes pour la qualité
de ce rapport je dirais qui peut-être ne
donne pas de
diagnostic sensiblement différents de ce
qui a déjà pu être produit qui est et
c'est bien simple direct concret et
concis et je vais m'inscrire dans trois
courtes questions la première
complètement dans le droit fil
je sais pas si c'est rassurant mais mais
de ce côté là plutôt de ce que vient
d'évoquer le présent rénal à la fin de
son propos
c'est lorsque vous dites et on peut
l'entendre que il faudrait supprimer
le taux le taux réduit un syndrome de
cas parce que il est inefficace
et quand on regarde par exemple
la hausse des taux de TVA que de telle
suppression si on pense par exemple aux
abonnements sur le gaz naturel
encouragé d'ailleurs par la directive de
d'avril 2022 et ce qui est effectivement
en période inflationniste vous pensez
que au-delà de trouver une justification
au titre de la transition énergétique
c'est une mesure qui sera ou qui serait
facilement compréhensible et non
seulement mais facile à mettre en oeuvre
je vais venir sur un deuxième sujet qui
est celui qui touche à la fraude à la
TVA vous avez vous l'avez évoqué on a de
notre côté également
produit un certain nombre de
recommandations
dans la une mission d'information de la
commission dont j'étais le rapporteur
donc nous en avons adopté un certain
nombre au Sénat notamment en particulier
l'extension des compétences des
officiers fiscaux judiciaires aux
escroqueries dans ce qui concerne la TVA
qui est resté dans le texte final mais
mais selon vous quels sont les mesures
les plus susceptibles de faciliter la
lutte contre la fraude atva notamment
dans le domaine du numérique enfin
troisième sujet qui reprend le sujet des
affectations vous avez évoqué bloc
fiscal et local perte je dirais ou
diminution rapide
me semble-t-il un peu dangereuse de la
TVA au bénéfice enfin hier au bénéfice
de l'État aujourd'hui
davantage et même de manière minoritaire
pour l'État au bénéfice du bloc
comment dirais-je social et local
est-ce que vous avez
au CPO une doctrine que vous appelez de
vos vœux pour l'avenir en matière
justement d'affectation de la TVA aux
organismes de sécurité sociale et aux
collectivités territoriales et peut-être
question
comment dirais-je additionnels en
l'absence de LPFP quel véhicule normatif
pourrait le mieux articuler votre
doctrine en la matière parce que je vous
cache pas que ça devient difficile mais
je sais que vous partagez
la préoccupation je ne sais pas à quel
moment le gouvernement va nous présenter
une copine et qu'elle en sera le contenu
merci Monsieur à papa général je suis
président peut-être quelques premières
réponses merci monsieur le Président
merci le rapporteur général
sur il y a tout de même une différence
notable entre le rapport de 2015 et le
rapport de cette année c'est que le
paysage a quand même radicalement changé
passé de 93% des recettes qui sont vers
l'état à la moitié en
8 ans c'est dire que le paysage des
finances locales changer
considérablement l'affectation a été
considérablement modifiée et ça fait
comme une assez grosse différence par
rapport à 2015 le rapport aboutit à des
conclusions qui je crois cette fois-ci
sont plus nettes et plus anglais parce
que la situation a également changé et
du coup l'impératif de rendement est
incontestablement plus aigu maintenant
deuxième remarque en réponse au
président sur l'Union européenne
j'évoquais brièvement le fait que
c'est vrai que l'Union européenne
souhaitait un peu rendre la main aux
États il se trouve que j'ai été pendant
cette période antérieure quand on a
lancé ses révisions le commissaires en
charge de cette question
après avoir été misé finance
j'avais vraiment la conviction et je
l'ai toujours que renvoyer à Bruxelles
le choix ou la décision sur les taux
réduits c'est un détour qui est un
productif en vérité qui est une facilité
et donc il va aller mieux en
l'occurrence aller vers davantage de
subsidiarité mais c'est vrai que ça crée
du coup aussi des tentations et que ça
complique le jeu politique sans aucun
doute mais il se passe maintenant à
l'échelle où il doit se passer c'est à
dire davantage à l'échelle nationale
quelle échelle européenne et je trouve
ça sain pas pour question qui sont
celles de du rapporteur général je vais
les prendre dans l'ordre où il a pris
bon nous ne sommes pas en train de
proposer je le dis
te supprimer massivement les taux
réduits nous disons simplement que si
des évolutions doivent avoir lieu elles
iraient plutôt dans le sens de supprimer
les taux réduits inefficaces que
d'augmenter le nombre de taux réduit
encore cette inefficacité pourquoi
d'abord le constat les taux de TVA
réduits sont coûteux pour les finances
publiques et ils sont très peu efficaces
économiquement j'ai dit que ces mesures
représentent un coup d'au moins 47
milliards c'est comme l'équivalent de 24
% du rendement de la TVA en 2021 et
c'est ce que nous perdons pour des
usages dont je pense ici vous ne me
contredirez pas ils sont nécessaires je
pense aux collectivités locales et je
pense aux organismes de sécurité sociale
le coût des dépenses fiscales de TVA a
doublé entre 2001 et 2022 passant 9,3 à
17 milliards d'euros le poids de ces
mesures apparaît beaucoup plus élevé que
dans le reste de l'Union européenne en
fin de la littérature récente a plutôt
tendance à favoriser un taux unique de
TVA l'existence de torrélie pouvant être
théoriquement justifiée dans des cas
très rares tels que la poursuite d'un
objectif d'équité taxation des biens
dans la production et source d'extérité
négatives le soutien ponctuel un secteur
en difficulté
ce sont vraiment
insiste des instruments inefficaces de
politique économique et qui génère
beaucoup de complexité à la fois pour
les entreprises et pour l'administration
conséquence je vais reformuler ma
proposition
l'adoption de nouveaux taux réduites
doit être vraiment évité au profit de
modalités révisée de suivi et
d'évaluation des modalités des
rogatoires existantes et à cet égard
nous ont deux recommandations la
première c'est de confier au CPO qui
sait le faire qui serait le faire ou à
une instance Haddock l'examen des taux
réduits en identifiant leurs objectifs
en évaluant leur atteinte et en
proposant des mesures plus efficaces et
plus efficientes le cas échéant car il
s'agirait pas de faire renoncer les
bénéficiaires assez taux réduit il
s'agira de substituer d'autres mesures
de petits comiques qui seraient plus
ciblées plus efficace et puis la
deuxième
supprimer donc les taux réduits de TVA
dont les évaluations confirmeraient
l'efficacité à défaut de leur
suppression
les relever un taux super dans le barème
je ne méconnais pas la difficulté
politique de l'exercice je ne crois pas
que ça aurait un effet inflationniste
mais c'est sûr que politiquement c'est
pas simple pour ce qui est de la fraude
dans le contexte de la numérisation de
l'économie les travaux récents l'Insee
révalus substantiellement les
estimations de la fraude de la TVA en
dépit de la modernisation du contrôle
fiscal des évolutions du régime de
territorialité de TVA les chiffrages
identifie un phénomène de plus grande
ampleur
l'estimation en 2015 de 10 milliards
d'euros a été réévalué à une fourchette
comprise entre 20 et 26 milliards
d'euros donc là aussi en 8 ans on voit
quand même progression très nette les
moyens et l'organisation du contrôle
fiscal ont été renforcés l'organisation
de l'autorité judiciaire des services
d'enquête en France au niveau européen
inconnu profond changement depuis 2015
mais face au développement du commerce
en ligne le cadre juridique des
importations
BtoC des tatiaires étaient profondément
transformées par la directive du 5
décembre 2017 relative à la TVA sur le
commerce électronique c'est celle que
j'appelle e-commerce conséquence la TVA
a l'air numérique doit s'habiller sur de
nouveaux instruments de lutte contre la
fraude et de simplification pour les
entreprises nous ont à cet égard de
recommandations d'abord de définir une
méthodologie
destinée à évaluer le montant de la
fraude de la TVA et de communiquer
annuellement les résultats au Parlement
ça c'est je crois l'administration de le
faire et puis deuxièmement de renforcer
la fraude la lutte contre la fraude à
TVA dans le contexte de l'économie des
plateformes à travers l'évaluation de
l'efficacité des obligations de
reporting des plateformes de mise en
relation par voie électronique
l'adaptation de la programmation du
contrôle fiscal pour tenir compte des
obligations de reporting des
prestataires de services de paiement le
soutien une réforme au niveau européen
du régime de redevabilité des
plateformes des services de transport et
d'hébergement
enfin solution de l'affectation des
recettes de TVA d'autres personnes
publiques que l'État je vais répéter mon
message là aussi il est simple direct
très clair
la TVA et c'est pour ça que nous
privions du rendement est un impôt
rendement dynamique
aisément recouvrables et neutre sur le
plan économique elle a été conçue comme
ça c'est un impôt de rendement c'est la
principale composante des impôts
indirects et elle présente de très
nombreux avantages pour les finances
publiques elle est dynamique elle est
très prévisible elle présente aussi
beaucoup d'avantages pour l'économie
elle est une imposition en théorie
neutre pour les entreprises elle ne
pénalise pas l'économie nationale
et si au contraire on allait vers une
affectation croissante de la TVA
d'autres personnes publiques
on constaterait ce qui se passe déjà
c'est à dire que vraiment cette
affectation c'est effondré en 8 ans
51% du produit en 2021 contre 93% en
2015 et ça s'est poursuivi 2021
l'affectation des TVA aux organismes de
sécurité sociale étaient quadruplées en
2019 passant de 6% des recettes de TVA à
24% en 2019 l'affectation des recettes
de TVA jouent un rôle majeur vous le
savez bien de la réforme de la fiscalité
locale en cours désormais 20% des
recettes de TVA bénéficient
collectivités et la TVA va constituer le
premier type de ressources collectivités
dès 2023
les risques associés à la vectation la
TVA d'autres personnes publiques que
l'État existent c'est d'abord un risque
majeur de soutenabilité pour les
finances publiques puisque les marches
de manoeuvre de l'État sont limitées
alors que les besoins eux sont
croissants et il y a des effets indésira
nombreux documentés par le CPO inhérents
au moins de contrôle parlementaire mais
oui et à la complexification du pilotage
des politiques publiques et donc là
aussi nous ont une recommandation qui
est d'éviter les affectations de TVA en
dehors du champ des organisées
protection sociale et territoriales
faisant remarquer au passage que de
toute façon par la loi organique ce sera
interdit en 2025 autant franchement ne
pas charger la barque d'ici là il faudra
d'ailleurs revoir à ce moment-là les
autres ressources il y en a une que j'ai
cité peut-être vous en souvenez enfin
monsieur le rapporteur général moi j'ai
pas de j'ai pas d'alternative je vous
redire ici mon message à une loi de
programmation de finance publique je
suis président de la Cour des comptes
nous sortons demain notre rapport public
que je remettrai au président de la
République d'une représenté au Sénat
dans quelques semaines il y a un
chapitre sur les finances publiques
le Haut Conseil des finances publiques
que je préside également et
régulièrement saisi des trajectoires
finances publiques des lois de
programmation sectorielles
on ne peut pas
travailler sérieusement sans avoir des
valeurs de référence sans avoir un
objectif de moyen terme bref sans avoir
de loi de programmation de finances
publiques c'est pas un gadget c'est pas
optionnel c'est indispensable et je
pense que ça pose de très sérieux
problèmes que l'absence d'une telle loi
de programmation suite dont j'ajouterai
qu'elle doit être également réaliste et
reposer sur des hypothèses crédibles
voilà mon sentiment et donc je vais pas
essayer d'inventer autre chose Monsieur
vapeur général je vais renouveler mon
appel et je le ferai à nouveau dès
demain quand je présenterai le rapport
public de la Cour des comptes à ce
qu'une loi de programmation de finance
publique soit adoptée au plus tôt nous
en avons collectivement je parle sur
tous les bancs besoin le travail
autrement matière de finances publiques
n'est pas sérieux sans cela je pense
qu'il a une problématique sur le plan
juridique mais je vais sortir de mon
champ et donc je vais m'arrêter
je sais pas si vous sortez de votre
chambre mais en tout cas vous vous
rappelez
les fondamentaux bon bien juridique le
reste j'assume complètement j'ai compris
il y a d'autres institutions qui sont
chargées de ça très bien alors
Vincent Delahaye puis Didier Rambo
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président merci pour ce rapport dont
je partage vrai dire les conclusions
quelques questions quelques propositions
sur les questions sur la fraude je vois
que la gestion de la crise sanitaire a
fait baisser les recettes liées au
contrôle fiscaux sur la TVA ce que c'est
le télétravail est-ce que c'est
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé cette année là
on nous a dit que tout le monde
travaillait de la même façon et j'ai
l'impression que en 2020 et 2021 il y a
eu une sacrée baisse donc c'était c'est
ma première question la deuxième
question
plutôt une proposition c'est à dire que
moi je pense qu'il faut effectivement
pas baisser la TVA je pense même qu'il
faut l'augmenter
et il faut l'augmenter d'une façon
générale pour baisser la CSG et ça va
avec vos conclusions de la page 9 ou
vous dites que sur le plan de l'économie
j'ai plus efficace une baisse de la CSG
qui une baisse de la TVA donc moi je
suis là pour ce qu'on a appelé peut-être
la TVA sociale à un moment donné mais je
pense qu'il faut la faire alors on va on
va nous dire c'est une période
d'inflation il faut se méfier enfin dans
les périodes où il y a pas d'inflation
on peut pas le faire dans la période de
l'inflammation va nous dire c'est
l'inflation il faut pas le faire moi je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui serait
très
utile et nécessaire
alors ensuite sur le le nombre de taux
réduits je ne sais pas combien il y a
d'auto réduit en fait je sais combien il
y a une niche fiscales une le nombre de
taux réduits je ne l'ai pas je sais plus
si vous l'avez mais moi je serais
preneur effectivement d'une évaluation
de l'efficacité économique l'efficacité
tout court disons de ces taux réduit
c'était marqué
[Musique]
attendez je ne vois pas il y a pas il y
a pas le nom mais le nombre de taux le
nombre de de secteurs qui qui sont qui
sont touchés par ces taux c'est pas le
nombre de taux réduits c'est le nombre
de secteurs voilà si vous avez une
évaluation à faire vous allez être
obligé d'en faire la liste et de dire
voilà il y a tellement de réduction pour
tel secteur et c'est la même chose que
pour les niches et est-ce que notre
commission des finances ne pourrait pas
demander à la Cour des comptes ce
travail dans le cadre des contrôles
annuels est-ce qu'on peut pas demander à
ce qui est un travail d'évaluation
effectivement de l'efficacité des taux
réduits dans les différents secteurs et
alors vous allez dire que je me
contredis mais moi je suis pour un taux
zéro sur l'eau et l'électricité parce
que c'est deux secteurs sur lesquels on
peut contrôler que le taux s'appliquer
réellement dire que il y a des secteurs
la restauration par exemple quand on a
baissé le taux dans la restauration
c'est très bien que une grosse partie de
la baisse est allée dans les marges des
restaurateurs par contre sur l'eau
l'électricité c'est très facile de
contrôler et c'est quand même deux
excusez-moi monsieur le Président mais
il y a beaucoup de choses à dire sur la
TVA et comme j'ai pas encore totalement
fini je vais quand même poursuivre un
tout petit peu je me suis pas beaucoup
exprimé dans l'hémicycle ces derniers
jours on a peut-être le faire en
commission
en comique je vais le faire un tout
petit peu plus mais
en tout cas j'aimerais avoir votre avis
sur un taux à zéro sur l'eau électricité
bon voilà je vais finalement merci m'en
tenir là pour faire plaisir aux
présidents c'est gentil merci et à nos
collègues qui vont pouvoir s'exprimer
ainsi alors Didier Rambaud puis Vanina
Paoli
merci monsieur le Président une remarque
et une question ma remarque j'ai envie
de dire que depuis que je siège au sein
de cette commission des finances c'est
pour moi peut-être le rapport le plus
important que j'ai lu et que j'écoute
parce que quelque part il remet un petit
peu la mairie au centre du village
rappelait quand même que la TVA c'est
vrai c'est un impôt de rendement et j'ai
envie de dire dans la continuité de
skyprimé Claude Raynal sans provocation
que c'est un document que chaque
parlementaire devrait avoir au coin de
la table notamment la veille de l'examen
de chaque PLF quand on voit tous les
toutes les demandes de taux réduit de
TVA qu'on reçoit parce que les uns et
les autres effectivement on a chacun nos
corporatismes qui qui nous assaillent
encore la semaine dernière au sein de la
mission
d'information sur le financement des des
autorités de mobilité on auditionnait le
garde et la seule proposition concrète
qui nous ont faites ça a été
effectivement de une demande de baisse
de taux de TVA réduit voilà et rappeler
parce qu'il y a une phrase importante
dans ce rapport que le taux normal
représente en moyenne en France 71 non
en Europe c'est 71% de l'assiette alors
qu'en France elle n'atteint que 65 % on
voit déjà un petit peu qu'on est allé
assez loin à ce sujet et puis sinon ma
question qui concerne la fraude mais ça
a été déjà un petit peu abordé par
Jean-François Husson on est quelques-uns
ici à participer à un groupe de travail
sous la présidence de Gabriel Attal qui
doit présenter dans les prochaines
semaines un plan fraude effectivement on
a envie d'être moi personnellement
d'être preneur de savoir quels sont les
moyens simples de renforcer un petit peu
l'efficacité des des contrôles et
d'améliorer ce recouvrement tant en
Europe qu'en France merci
merci Didier Evan il n'a pas obligé puis
Michel Canevet merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président du
Conseil merci beaucoup pour cette
présentation très instructive je
regrette un peu qu'on ne creuse pas la
question de ce qu'est la valeur ajoutée
en ce début de 21e siècle avec les défis
protéiformes qui s'imposent à nous c'est
un peu c'est un peu décevant je trouve
j'ai une question une suggestion la
première question rejoint celle de mon
prédécesseur c'est l'articulation en
fait de vos recommandations 2 et 3 avec
les travaux que nous conduisons sous la
houlette de Gabriel Attal donc
effectivement sur la fraude à la TVA
et la suggestion c'est effectivement il
faut pas multiplier les taux réduits etc
mais est-ce qu'il ne pourrait pas y
avoir une ligne de partage entre ce qui
serait une nouvelle valeur ajoutée c'est
à dire une valeur ajoutée qui serait
considérée à l'aune de la transition
écologique de la circularité de
l'économie et une TVA à taux normal
voire surélevé pour tous les produits en
fait qui ne participent pas de la
décarbonation des produits issus de
l'économie circulaire des produits
recyclés seraient tout à fait légitimes
à bénéficier de cette nouvelle valeur
ajoutée selon moi ce serait un chemin
vers une fiscalité plus personnalisée et
en cohérence avec la nature des produits
qui sont consommés par les personnes ce
serait plus équitable
et je pense que la mesure de
l'efficacité monsieur le Président ne
peut pas être que financière
merci Vanina puis Christine l'avare
merci monsieur le Président et à vos
équipes du CPO pour ce cinéma d'analyse
qui sont extrêmement intéressants cela
me conforte notamment sur l'idée que
la TVA est un impôts efficace notamment
pour le rendement pour nos finances
publiques et que dans la période que
l'on a connu ou un certain nombre de
propositions formulées des baisses de
TVA pour lutter contre
la hausse des prix et pour améliorer le
pouvoir d'achat et bien vous me
confortez dans l'idée que sur l'énergie
en particulier il fallait absolument pas
baisser les TVA il le convient de
peut-être d'utiliser d'autres outils
vous avez évoqué le chèque énergie mais
surtout pas baisser la TVA parce que
c'est quelque chose d'important et c'est
important aujourd'hui aussi vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le Président pour les
collectivités territoriales et donc il
faut qu'on y soit particulièrement
attentif alors vous avez évoqué de façon
spécifique la TVA pour le secteur
financier est-ce que vous voyez des
moyen d'améliorer le rendement de la TVA
sur le secteur financier est-ce qu'il y
a des
comment dire des modalités d'application
qui qu'il faudrait revoir assez
rapidement et puis dernier point comme
là évoqué Vincent delay est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous auriez vous auriez pu
étudier également
l'hypothèse d'une hausse du taux de TVA
notamment se comparant avec les autres
pays européens est-ce qu'il y a des
marges de manœuvre peut-être qui
existent à ce sujet
merci Michel Christine Labarde puis
Jean-Marie maison
merci monsieur le Président alors ce
rapport était très intéressant et je
pense qu'il va nous faire gagner
beaucoup de temps dans l'hémicycle lors
des prochains PLF sauf si on met
justement en oeuvre vos recommandations
et convient supprimer un certain nombre
de taux réduit pour aligner tout sur le
taux normal enfin en tout cas c'est ce à
quoi vous nous invitez sur la question
de la fraude moi je voudrais notamment
revenir sur la prise en compte des des
taux différenciés pour la partie de la
restauration entre la vente sur place et
la vente à emporter je pense qu'on a
tous constaté ici que bien souvent les
restaurateurs qui font de la vente à
emporter ne nous font pas une réduction
de 10% du prix de la facture et juste je
pendant que vous parliez j'ai été un peu
regardé et enfin vous allez comprendre
aussi pourquoi tout est extrêmement
compliqué je vais juste vous citer les
produits de pâtisserie qui peuvent
bénéficier de taux réduit lorsqu'ils
sont à base de pâte ou de meringue et
dans la confection desquels intervient
l'un des composants suivants crème pâte
d'amande fruit autre que confits et sec
et préparation de fruits donc donc déjà
sur ce qu'elle a vous comprenez bien que
le pauvre pâtissier boulanger il va même
être incapable de savoir s'il doit vous
mettre un taux à 5 ou un taux à 10 et un
peu plus loin on parle des crèmes
glacées et donc si vous faites une crème
glacée dans un bac en gros je comprends
que vous pouvez avoir un taux réduit
mais par exception les glaces vendu à
l'unité sont soumises autant
intermédiaire de 10 %. donc est-ce
qu'une classe encore née est un à 5 ou à
10 puisqu'elle est par définition unique
donc peut-être qu'effectivement une
partie de la fraude elle pourrait aussi
être résolue juste par des questions de
de simplification et juste j'aurais
voulu avoir quelques éclaircissements
sur la différence de sémantique entre
les recommandations 10 et 11 puisque
dans la recommandation 11 vous dites
d'écarter la modulation des taux de TVA
comme instrument de santé publique en
matière nutritionnelle et pour autant
dans un principe un peu de
pollueur-payeur moi je suis pas choqué
que ceux qui ont des consommations avec
des produits nuisibles à la santé paye
plus cher que ceux qui consomment que de
l'eau qui n'a pas de
de contre-indication sur la santé et
finalement pourquoi est-ce que vous
dites pas au lieu d'écarter les
modulations de TVA de dire finalement
renforcer les assises puisque
aujourd'hui il existe un certain nombre
de taxes sur les boissons
nocives les boissons alcoolisées les
boissons sucrées les boissons donc
est-ce que c'est pas enfin voilà c'était
juste pour comprendre quoi vous aviez
pas choisi le même type de
recommandations pour ces deux secteurs
l'environnement et
merci Christine vous nous avez ouvert
l'appétit
à la fois glace boisson bon
merci Jean-Marie maison merci monsieur
le Président ma question porte sur la
fraude fiscale j'ai été il y a quelques
temps président d'une mission
d'information sur la lutte contre
l'électronisme et pour l'inclusion
numérique et le public concernait
n'était pas au nombre de celui qui
fraude à la TVA je parle de cela parce
que dans votre rapport vous soulignez
que la Commission européenne a suggéré
aux États membres d'intensifier les
efforts en matière d'analyse des risques
d'automatisation des processus et
d'échanges d'informations et invite
l'administrations fiscale a recruter
plus d'informaticiens et investir de la
science des données je ne sais pas si le
Condate cette suggestion de la
Commission européenne mais est-ce
qu'elle a été vraiment suivie des faits
je rappelle aussi que le recrutement
d'informaticiens n'est pas une chose
facile puisqu'il en manque beaucoup
merci Jean-Marie Jean-Baptiste blanc
puis Georges patient
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Président
on a bien vu que le la TVA servait à
financer les collectivités locales la
part est de plus en plus importantes et
je voulais vous interroger là-dessus
éventuellement parmi les nouvelles
missions des collectivités locales
figurent la transition écologique dans
cette transition écologique le zan
qui va évidemment nécessiter un portage
financier et faire les citer qu'on fasse
preuve d'imagination fiscale à l'avenir
pour maîtriser le foncier et pour
trouver là une nouvelle autonomie
financière peut-être en tout cas
réinventer la fiscalité locale le zan
c'est le début vraiment de la transition
écologique portée par les territoires
alors il y a le fond vert qui existe à
hauteur de 2 milliards mais c'est qu'il
ne suffiront sans doute pas à l'avenir
le CPO saisit par cette commission à
rendu un rapport absolument
passionnant c'est une matière qu'on va
travailler dans les prochaines semaines
pour et qui concerne d'ailleurs 6 ou 7
impôts et taxes parmi lesquels ne
figureraient pas la TVA mais ma question
est la suivante c'est que pensez-vous
que la TVA puisse en clair accompagner
les collectivités
qui vont porter la transition écologique
ce sont elles seules qui vont le faire
pensez-vous en particulier que la TVA
puisse aider à financer Lausanne
je vous remercie merci Jean-Baptiste
Georges patient
oui monsieur le Président il y a une
volonté forte du gouvernement de
remplacer l'octroi de mer dans les
outre-mer ou bien de liens trop dur pour
les territoires qui pour l'instant ne
sont pas
frappés par
la TVA
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez quand on
sait quand même que l'octroi de mer et
la principale ressource des
collectivités locales d'outre-mer et que
le coût est approximativement d'un
milliard 200 millions
merci Georges
j'aurai moi une question plutôt de de un
peu de compréhension
sur
le la question de la contribution du
secteur financier donc sera votre
rapport évoque la question d'une juste
contribution du secteur financier au
budget des États membres mais un peu
plus loin il propose d'alléger via le
régime d'options et le régime de groupe
les charges fiscales qui pèsent sur ce
secteur alors c'est sans doute pas une
contradiction mais si vous ne pouvez
nous préciser un petit peu les choses ce
serait peut-être
utile merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs avec votre
permission je partagerai la réponse avec
Patrick Lefa qui donnera quelques
précisions bon d'abord je voudrais vous
remercier de votre appréciation de ce
rapport
qui
volontairement court qui est en effet
très direct qui sans vouloir être
directif à des conclusions nettes parce
que il se veut une aide à la décision à
la réflexion je suis heureux que vous le
preniez comme tel et je me gardais
d'improviser au-delà du rapport
vous êtes la représentation nationale
c'est à vous aussi de faire des
propositions en la matière et le CPO
n'est absolument pas vocation à faire
votre travail et votre place donc je
m'en tiendrai ainsi Patrick Lefa ce qui
figure ici même si bien sûr nous sommes
très sensibles aux propositions qui ont
été faites je vais me contenter
peut-être de quelques réflexions plus
plus générale
sur la fraude sur lequel plusieurs
d'entre vous sont intervenus
je rappelle que nous proposons de
confier
au CPO
un rôle en la matière et en effet dans
l'observatoire de lutte contre la fraude
qui doit être mise en place
la Cour des comptes ou le CPO sont tout
prêts à jouer leur rôle j'aurais
l'occasion de mon entretenir dans les
prochaines semaines avec le
ministre des comptes publics Gabriel
Attal mais il va de soi que dans cette
période nous sommes vivants très
mobilisés que ce soit sur la revue des
dépenses publiques ou sur lutte contre
la fraude je rappelle aussi
à la demande du Sénat c'était par
exemple la commission des affaires
sociales nous avions par exemple réalisé
un rapport que j'avais l'occasion de
présenter devant vous sur la lutte
contre la fraude ou prestation sociale
j'appelle enfin que mon prédécesseur
didimigo avait lui-même présidé une
mission à la demande
c'est pas du président de la République
et du Premier ministre sur la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale en général tout
sujet que nous pouvons reprendre
monsieur le Président à la demande de la
commission des finances
dans les modifications qui ont été
adoptées récemment je rappelle qu'il est
aussi possible maintenant au Parlement
de saisir le CPO dans des conditions
bien précises mais de même façon que la
commission des finances saisit la Cour
des comptes il est possible aussi de
demander des rapports au CPO nous sommes
disponibles pour travailler
et oui mais nous sommes prêts à le faire
sur d'autres sujets comme la fraude
c'est une perche que je tendais ou
plutôt que je récupérerai des
interventions de plusieurs sénateurs sur
les taux de réduit de TVA de même
il y a une recommandation je le redis
qui propose de confier au CPO ou à une
instance Haddock l'examen des taux
réduits en identifiant les leurs
objectifs en évaluant leur atteinte en
proposant des mesures plus efficaces et
plus efficiente que échéance ça pourrait
être le cas sur la TVA social parmi
d'autres et en effet nous sommes
naturellement prêts aussi à travailler
sur les différents produits etc etc
c'est un travail que nous pouvons
approfondir là encore
je me demande s'il faut vraiment créer
une instance Adobe quand il y a le CPO
mais les deux possibilités existent en
réalité ils ont quand même beaucoup
renforcé le CPO c'est une institution
que vous connaissez qui est plus
réaliste dans sa composition
y compris des élus et donc qui je pense
peut jouer là où le extrêmement
utile
sur la fraude là encore
je rappelle notamment sur le
numérisation de l'économie que nous
proposons de définir une méthodologie
destinée à évaluer le montant de la
fraude de la TVA et communiquer
annuellement les résultats au Parlement
qui notre interlocuteur naturel et de
renforcer la lutte contre la faudra
évidemment le contexte de l'économie de
plateforme plusieurs propositions sont
faites à ce sujet par rapport aux
questions qui ont été posées sur les la
fiscalité environnementale et
nutritionnelle je vais pas rentrer moi
non plus dans le menu qui a proposé
madame l'avare mais je
quand en effet que nous avons une
proposition très précise bon d'abord
considérons que ce n'est pas un
instrument efficace ni pour la fiscalité
environnementale ni pour le fiscalité
nutritionnelle donc c'est un point
commun mais en effet s'agissant de
l'environnement nous suggérons de
préférer les accessises à la TVA comme
principal instrument de fiscalité
incitative en matière environnementale
nous proposons simplement d'écarter la
modulation des TVA comme instrument de
santé publique en matière nutritionnelle
mais nous descartons pas du tout ce qui
concerne le nutri-score et pourquoi pas
les assises donc c'est vrai que c'est
pas rédigé exactement la même façon mais
vous connaissez bien la façon dont on
rédige à la Cour des comptes on essaye
en général ne pas se répéter peut-être
est-ce une élégance de plumes mais en
l'occurrence la logique est quand même
exactement la même enfin pour moi je
serai Patrick poursuivre pour ce qui
concerne
l'origine du taux de TVA du secteur
financier il y a un constat c'est que
l'exonération des activités bancaires
financière et d'assurance n'est que
partielle et
c'est une conséquence c'est que dans le
contexte actuel qui est un contexte pose
brexit le régime de TVA du secteur
financier pourrait être modernisé des
réflexions sont en cours au Royaume-Uni
sur la réforme des exemptions des
services financiers pour assurer une
plus grande compétitivité secteur qui
est très importante de ce pays et dans
ce contexte le régime de TVA du secteur
financier pour être moins deux
directions l'actualisation au niveau
européen du périmètre et des notions du
régime d'options et puis une réflexion
sur l'usage des règles d'exonération
avec droit à déduction à des fins
compétitives nous recommandons à cet
effet de moderniser le régime de TVA du
secteur financier en réactualisant le
périmètre et les notions du régime
d'options et en conduisant une réflexion
sur le gel des règles d'exonération avec
trois déductions à des fins compétitifs
j'ajoute des gens finis pour ce qui me
concerne qu'en effet il faut une
réflexion économique plus large sur la
valeur ajoutée et sur la façon dont
cette impôt
ça peut être à travers la fiscalité des
tas ou l'affectation à l'état ou aux
collectivités locales peut-être utilisée
à des fins qui sont des fins plus plus
ambitieuses mais encore une fois nous
pensons que ce n'est pas le meilleur
outil
c'est pas le meilleur outil pour des
politiques économiques quelle qu'elle
soit c'est avant tout et c'est comme le
message central un impôt de rendement
qu'il faut préserver et dont il faut
aussi préserver les affectations Patrick
lefaste
à mon propos merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président oui peut-être en complément
alors d'abord ce qui a été pointé qui
est une la baisse des recettes enfin des
redressement liées au contrôle cette
dans la page 30 24 pardon du rapport
effectivement ce qui ça renvoie en fait
à la à la problématique de
comment est-ce qu'il faut maintenant
renforcer les moyens du contrôle et
surtout les outils et donc c'est tout
l'enjeu en fait du ce qu'on appelle le
data mining d'où l'utilité d'avoir des
des experts qui sont à même de traiter
au travers de l'intelligence
artificielle
à certains membres de données extérieur
vous avez vu l'affaire des piscines bon
ben ça c'est au fait le résultat du
contrôle du contrôle fiscal qui permet
effectivement d'être plus efficace donc
ça c'est le c'est le premier le premier
aspect de la de la réponse le deuxième
c'est que
c'est un petit peu les dispositions que
vous avez vous avez voté vers la
facturation électronique et donc tout le
paquet
numérique qu'on attend de la de la
Commission européenne que le premier
président a cité
les propositions de la Commission de
décembre 2022 qui vont mettre le
l'accent sur les problématiques
d'interopérabilité donc de favoriser les
échanges d'informations entre
administration fiscale donc là on a en
fait un champ important pour
lutter contre une fraude qui est
changé de nature du fait du
développement considérable
de commerce électronique commerce à
distance et donc des problématiques où
on a des acteurs qui sont assujettis et
des acteurs qui ne sont pas assujettis à
la TVA et d'où l'enjeu de du paquet
numérique et donc il y a un certain
nombre de recommandations que nous
faisons la matière sur le le nombre de
taux réduits on n'a pas la réponse mais
à vrai dire l'essentiel en fait du de
taux réduit c'est ce qui avait été
initialement posé comme exception
dans par la France quand on a négocié la
première directive TVA et et depuis on a
multiplié en fait des exceptions et plus
vous multipliez les exceptions plus en
réalité on aboutit aux contradictions
qui ont été évoquées très justement en
matière nutritionnelle donc il y a les
bombs de chocolat il y a les les
conditions dans lesquelles la viande de
taureau peut être taxer à la TVA vous
avez une directive une instruction de de
la DG fit qui fait une dizaine de pages
sur le sur le sujet donc voilà c'est
plus on a des exceptions plus on a
matière a été à compenser les écarts au
nom de l'égalité de concurrence mais
sauf des grandes perturbations pour ceux
qui ont appliquer et deuxièmement des
opportunités de fraude sur la baisse de
la TVA à la restauration enfin qui a
d'abord une messe et puis qui a été
remontée à 10% on a bien vu dans les
études académiques ont été menées en
dernier lieu celle de l'Institut du
politique publique que
ceux qui avaient empoché la différence
c'était essentiellement les
propriétaires de restaurant c'est eux
qui
en poche 54% de la de l'effet de
l'avantage lié
donc ça veut bien dire que
quand on prétend avoir un souci de
création d'emplois pour justifier une
baisse de taux de taux il faut
évidemment avant regarder s'il y a pas
de solutions alternatives qui le
justifierait sur le
les taux zéro eau électricité à vrai
dire
parce que nous recommandons pour les
raisons qui ont été expliquées tout à
l'heure par le premier président c'est
que
des taux zéros ça arrose tout le monde
donc c'est il vaut mieux des
dépenses ciblées le chèque le chèque est
énergie est certainement une bonne
mesure parce qu'elle est totalement
ciblée et donc elle a l'effet correcteur
qui est qui est attendu plutôt qu'une un
taux qui va avoir un effet
transversal pour l'ensemble des
abonnés à l'eau et l'électricité
sur le zan oui dès lors que la TVA est
affectée aux collectivités territoriales
elle a vocation à
financer ce type ce type de
d'obligation qui vont peser sur sur les
entreprises non pas en termes de de
compensation mais en termes d'incitation
et donc c'est un sujet qui nous semble
nous sacralisons en disant que il faut
limiter les affectations de recettes de
TVA aux organismes de protection sociale
d'une part et aux collectivités
territoriales d'autre part
sur
sur la fraude je crois que le président
a répondu
ah oui comment
outre-mer sur l'outre-mer en fait c'est
un sujet que nous n'avons l'octroi de
mer nous savons que c'est un sujet très
très important mais à vrai dire nos
collègues de l'Inspection générale des
finances était en train de travailler
sur le sujet et donc en fait nous
n'avons pas regardé le point mais c'est
un sujet si vous nous saisissez on
pourrait éventuellement le traiter si le
rapport de l'Inspection générale des
finances ne vous donnez pas satisfaction
sur l'éclairage des conditions dans
lesquelles satisfaction
je suis obligé de le dire devant le
rapporteur général
non mais c'est un sujet très important
j'ai eu à m'occuper et à Paris à
Bruxelles et je crois qu'il faudra un
jour quand même effectivement trancher
la question et avancer de manière
décisive
voilà
très bien merci beaucoup messieurs merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de femmes c'est le rapporteur
général merci de d'être venu pour cette
audition et nous éclairer sur ce rapport
du CPO
je suspends la séance 2 minutes le temps
de raccompagner le président